our subject how supreme is the supreme court
our theme for the weekend watch and
pray god is good and all the time
when you say that do you say god is good because
you are required to say that or do you say god
is good because you have personal experience in
your lives well let's try that again god is good
and all the time the bible says in
psalm 100 verse 5 for the lord is good
when god sent the flood he was good when
he destroyed sodom and gomorrah by fire
he was good when he allowed
the romans to destroy jerusalem
he was good when he sent the israelites
into babylonian captivity one of the
reasons was consistent sabbath breaking he
was good when he destroyed sinners by fire
he will be good god is always good somebody
say amen the bible says in psalm 145 verse 17
the lord is righteous in all his ways and holy
in all his works in other words god cannot do
something wrong so on the occasions you and i have
been angry with god we were temporarily insane
that's very serious we were and by
the way we ought to apologize to god
you cannot get angry with a god who makes no
mistakes when that same infallible god seems
almost endlessly patient with us who specialize in
mistakes and so we say one more time god is good
and all the time let me hear the princesses
of heaven god is good and all the time
let me hear the princes and the rulers god is good
and all the time let me hear the whole family
god is good and all the time thank you for that
for god you're very good looking audience thank
you for that may i count myself as one of you
well why not who is with us who is not a
seventh-day adventist makes your hand we
had one last night sister jasmine i don't know if
she's here again where is she where is she where
where oh okay okay okay blessings blessings
blessings i saw your hand would you kindly stand
tell us your name please what's your name your
name is somebody shouted for me monica hello
monica how are you you look nice this morning
who invited you your your son what's his name
david ah good bible david stand
up let's take a look at you
come on say amen for david david thank you for
bringing your mother sister monica my good sister
we're delighted you accepted the invitation
thank you and may god bless everything you
do brother david may the lord bless you and give
you a good looking wife let the church say amen
all right brother david good man sharp looking
brother anyone else you're not a seventh-day
adventist but you're with us mess your hand anyone
else anyone else you may be hiding somewhere
we're always honored to have non-seventh-day
adventists with us all right before i get into
the message which is how supreme is the
supreme court please turn your phones off
i know you have them how many of you were here
last night you heard my ranting and raving
what's this what's that what is this not this
is not a bible always remember that so please
uh turn your phones off another reason why
this is a better choice whatsapp is not on this
what's that you've never heard of whatsapp
well it's in michigan it's not in california
you don't have whatsapp do you have
skype in california skype is not on here
email is not in this bible are you with me what
am i saying when you use this as a bible and you
open it to find the text you may be tempted to
see who sent me a text and it will not be jesus
but when you open this all you have is
the right kind of text can you say amen
use this bring this but use this
and the one people should see you have is this
not that no one tries to steal
this they'll try to steal that
so let them see this and not that all phones are
off i expect and hope you accommodate my request
fifth number two while i'm speaking pray for me
and say lord put your words in that man's mouth
and i mean that from the foundation of my soul
pray for me and faith number three i want you to
think not i god isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together saith the lord mark 12 reading from verse
28 and one of the scribes came and having
heard them reasoning together and perceiving
that he answered them well jesus reasoned acts 17
verse 2 acts 18 verse 4 acts 24 25 paul reasoned
heads bowed eyes closed our father in
heaven we thank you thank god for life
we thank you father that we
still have freedom to worship
it will not last forever we thank you today
god for this facility made available to us
we thank you for all the organizers whose
thinking and planning you guided and led
dear god in heaven as we lift up your word
grant us your spirit who is the spirit of truth
jesus said in john 16 13 i'll be it when he
the spirit of truth is come he will guide
you into altar of dear god guide us into truth
i pray i humble myself before you their father
seeking no glory for myself but all
the glory for your deserving name
help me their god to speak the truth boldly
but compassionately for i too am a sinner
in a very special way blessed jasmine and blessed
sister monica who visiting with us we're grateful
for their presence bless their families hear
this prayer day god because we've offered it in
jesus name let god's people say amen and amen
our subject how supreme is the supreme court
our theme for the weekend watch and pray
the sponsoring department religious liberty
keeping this in mind religious
liberty will focus on the word liberty
at some point in the message let us go
to john 19 we shall read from verse one
we're reading from the king james version
of the bible john 19 reading from verse 1.
i can still hear pages sterling which is
good you have john 19 reading from verse 1
the bible says then pilate therefore took jesus
and scourged him and the soldiers planted a crown
of thorns and put it on his head and they put on
him a purple robe and said hail king of the jews
and they smote him with their hands pilate
therefore went forth again and saith unto them
behold i bring him forth to you that he may know
that i find no fault in him then came jesus forth
wearing the crown of thorns and the purple
robe and pilate unto them behold the man
when the chief priest therefore and officers saw
him they cried out saying crucify him crucify him
pilate saith unto them take ye him and crucify him
for i find nor fall in him the jews answered him
we have a law and by our law he ought to die
because he made himself the son of god verse 8
when pilate therefore heard that saying he
was the more afraid and went again into the
judgment hall and saith unto jesus whence art thou
where are you from but jesus gave him no answer
now pilate was a roman official he had the
power of life and death he asked christ a
direct question whence art thou where are you from
and perhaps by implication who really are you what
is it you want but jesus gave him noah christ was
not intimidated by the power of pilate and the man
or the woman who cannot be intimidated is
free even though the person may be handcuffed
shackled christ gave him no answer then said
pilate unto him verse 10 speakers thou not unto me
do you know who i am nor shall not that i
have power to crucify thee and have power to
release thee verse 11 praise god for that verse
it's the first every christian should live by
jesus answered read it with me if you have
my version thou couldest have no power at
all against me finish the verse
except it were given thee from above
therefore he that delivered me unto thee
hath the greatest and listen to the words
of christ thou could have no power at
all against me except it were given thee
from above what does jesus christ mean given
from above given by his father allowed by
his father permitted by his father for
reasons attached to the glory of the father
the republican party can have no power over
you at all except god allows them in power
the democratic party can have no power at all
against several day adventists i don't
know about the rest of the country
except it were given them by god you
and i need to understand we serve a god
that controls political affairs not your vote
in daniel chapter 2 reading from verse 20 when
god revealed nebuchadnezzar's dream to daniel
in verse 20 of daniel 2 the bible says daniel
answered and said blessed be the name of god
forever and ever for wisdom and might are his
now the united states is the most powerful
military power on the face of the earth the
bible says wisdom and might belong to god
and he changeth the times and the seasons
he removed with kings and setteth the kings
when we do not understand that we begin to stress
over who's in power and we argue democratic
adventists argue with republican adventists
and their splits and divisions in the church
yet we serve a god who controls the strings of
politics in this country and in the world listen
to daniel 1 reading from verse 1 in the third year
of jehoiakim king of judah came nebuchadnezzar
king of babylon unto jerusalem and besieged
it first though and the lord gave jehoiakim
king of judah into his hand
now a secular historian will study the sources
and write a book and say the military might of
the babylonians was greater than the defenses
of the israelites and so the israelites lost
no the bible says god gazed the israelites
into nebuchadnezzar's hand jericho was the most
heavily fortified city of the ancient world let
me say that again jericho was the most heavily
fortified city rehab lived on the wall the walls
were thick but god gave jericho to the israelites
we serve a who controls
every of every earthly power
is under the control of god and so when jesus
stood before pilate he stood before the might
of the roman empire and he was not intimidated
my brothers and sisters how
supreme is the supreme court
as the church we teach that someday in
the future a sunday law will be passed
making sunday observance required by law when
that law is passed then decisions have to be made
between the law originating from heaven
and the law originating from the earth
when people make that choice that's when we'll
have people who will have the mark of the beast
at this point no one has the mark of the beast
are you with me because there is not yet a legal
requirement to observe sunday as the sabbath
day but when that law is passed and the test
comes those who bend to an earthly law
are the ones who will be in bondage
those who realize i serve a god who controls
my destiny they're the ones who will choose
to serve god regardless of circumstances and i
submit to you that kind of attitude is freedom
man so jesus stood before pilate the might of the
roman empire the greatest empire at that time and
he told pilate you could have no power at all
not even a little power no power at all except
let me narrow it down make it more personal
if you're faithful to god listen to me carefully
if you're faithful to god you obey him from the
heart his will is your highest joy if you're
being harassed on the job god has allowed it
but remember the conditions i laid down if you're
faithful to god you know peter said in 1st peter
4 15 but let none of you suffer as a murderer
or as a thief or as an evil doer or as a busy
body in other men's matters that's not the way the
christian should suffer if the christian suffers
let it be because he or she is faithful to
god and god allows that person to be tested
and so jesus said you could have no
power against me except christ was free
could not be intimidated could not be threatened
could not be cowed into submission christ stood
in the liberty where with his father had made him
free you know galatians 5 1 paul says stand fast
therefore in the liberty where with christ hath
made you free and be not entangled again with
the yoke of bondage where the spirit of god is
second corinthians 3 17 there is liberty freedom
you can be changed and free
and this weekend is celebrating
religious liberty let's go to daniel chapter 3 now
our scripture reading we shall read from verse 8
it is what time is it
1 okay when do i end up all right i got about 12
36 37 that's what i looked at but uh we'll see
how merciful i'll be all right daniel chapter
3 we shall read from verse eight that's eight
well let's see well wherefore at that time certain
chaldeans came near or drew near and accused the
jews remember nebuchadnezzar made an image he
said everyone bowed three boys refused to bow
some chaldeans observed them and they came and
said listen these boys not bowing they spake and
said to the bekenhazza o king live forever thou
o king has made a decree and every man they shall
hear the sound of the cornet flute harp sackbut
solitary and dulcimer and all kinds of music shall
fall down and worship the golden image and also
fall down and worship it that he should be cast
into the midst of a burning fiery furnace that's
up to verse 11 verse 12 there are certain jews
listen again to the words of the bible
there are certain jews the verse doesn't say
they are all jews because most of the
jews were doing what they were bowing
there are certain jews whom thou has set over
the affairs of the province of babylon shadrach
meshach and abednego these men o king have not
regarded thee they serve not thy gods nor worship
the golden image which thou has set up there are
certain jews if you look at verse 8 wherefore at
that time certain chaldeans drew near there
are always certain chaldeans and certain jews
there are those who are faithful and they're
those who set out to make their lives miserable
question for you don't answer me
are you among the certain jews
let's drop jews we're in the last days all people
nations and languages have been called to observe
a day set up by congress as a holy day now
can god say there are certain adventists
who absolutely refuse to bow
regardless of loss of job loss of house
loss of income loss of prestige loss
of social support loss of family
there are certain jews
whom thou has set over the affairs of the kingdom
of babylon the province of babylon shadrach
meshach and abednego these men o king have not
regarded thee that's not disrespect to this regard
is not to disrespect if the government passes the
law and says you know you can kill your neighbor i
will disregard that law are you following me they
regarded the regard not the neither do they they
worship the golden image without has set up then
they became as a verse 13 in his rage and fury
commanded to bring shadrach meshach and abednego
then they brought these men before the king
now nebuchadnezzar was the most powerful man back
then he did not rule by committee the bible says
he killed whom he wanted to kill he released whom
he wanted to release when daniel refused to eat
the food the prince of the eunuchs was nervous
because he said the king will cut my head off
if you don't eat what he recommends and so on the
mechanism in his rage and fury commanded to bring
shadrach meshach and abednego then they brought
this moon before the king nebuchadnezzar speak
and said unto them is it true or shadrach
meshach and abednego i like the question
is it true do we not serve my gods nor worship
the golden image which i have set up by the way i
have set up he has set up recurs almost 11 times
in the first 18 verses of daniel 3. is it true
the world will ask us very shortly is it
true several advertisers don't work on subway
what should we say yes it's true will
all of us be able to say that no why
because some of us work on sabbath and
what's the reason i have to survive
is it true that seventh-day adventists
place a premium on the health message
what should we say yes will
all of us be able to say yes no
is it true 70 advocates believe be not an
equally oak with unbelievers is it true
what should we say yes can we all say yes no
is it true that there are conferences
that discourage the use of eloise
writings sadly the answer is yes
i was in a certain country
on the face of the earth
i was staying with a minister in that country
and he told me something i could not believe
the conference had circulated a document
requiring all the ministers to sign i
will not quote ellen white from the pope
is it true that says the advocates disregard
ella white's counsel the painful answer is yes
and so nebuchadnezzar said is it true oh shadrach
meshach and abednego do he not serve my gods nor
worship the golden image which i have set up
verse 15 now if he be ready but at what time
you hear the sound of the cornet flute heart sac
but sultamay and dulcimer on all kinds of music
he fall down and worship the images i have made
well it is never well to engage in idol worship
that's what nebuchadnezzar said if you do it
that's well but if not you shall be cast the same
hour into a burning fiery furnace finish the verse
with me and who is that god that shall deliver you
out of my head who you know sometimes we are in
the midst of circumstances and we see no way out
forgetting we serve a god for whom nothing
is impossible and so nebuchadnezzar said
i'd like to see that god you know pharaoh said
who is the lord and then the lord showed him
and it was very very painful god showed
nebuchadnezzar in the very next chapter
who he was shadrach michigan burma answered
and said to the king oh nebuchadnezzar verse
16 daniel 3 we are not careful to answer thee in
this matter if it be so our god whom we serve is
able to deliver us from the burning fiery furnace
and he will deliver us out of thy hand o king
as you heard last night from dr risinger
but if not
you know i like those words very much god needs
a lot of but if not in the church but if not
be it known unto the okay now i loved
is it true i also love be it known
you know how many christians hide who they are
and it's not known and because it's not known
many people never see the light of god's
love and by hiding your christianity by
hiding your adventism you deny someone the
privilege of observing adventism in operation
and so the three boys said
be it known unto thee o king
we want you to have no confusion no
misunderstandings we will not serve thy
gods nor worship the golden image which thou has
set up in other words there is nothing you can do
now to take that attitude as jesus took with
pilate the three hebrew boys with nebuchadnezzar
daniel with darius in daniel 6
you must lose the fear of death do you know
the fear of death is the worst form of slavery
listen to hebrews 2 verse 14 15 for as much
then as the children are partakers of flesh
and blood he also himself likewise took part in
the same that through death he might destroy him
that had the power of the death that is the
devil verse 15 and delivered them who through
fear of death were all their lifetime subject
to bondage a man who is afraid to die is a slave
as long as the devil sees i am afraid to die
the devil has the most powerful weapon to use
against me and that's the threat to my life
remember what the devil said to god skin for skin
all that a man hath really gave for what his life
he was wrong about job he was wrong with
a capital r is that how you spell wrong
he was wrong with a capital ah wrong
okay okay put the w he was just wrong
let me tell you something about
the devil the devil is afraid
of believers who are not afraid to die
ah you didn't hear me
you were sleeping with your eyes open you
didn't hear me the devil is afraid of believers
who are not afraid to die because the threat of
death is his most powerful weapon and so the three
hebrew boys said listen be it known unto your king
we will not serve thy gods nor worship the golden
image which thou hast said at first 19 daniel
3 then the big nazi was full of fury and the
former's visit was changed against shadrach
meshach and abednego therefore he spake and
commanded that they should heat the furnace one
seven times more than it was won't to be heated
now at that point i might have changed my mind
if i had a choice of death let me tell you
what i would not choose to be eaten by a bear
huh i wouldn't choose that i mean where
does he bite first i don't know i would not
choose to be burned in fire i would choose lethal
injection with a sanitized needle are you with me
i don't even want a scar where
the needle is i want laughing gas
something what's the word i'm
looking for painless and quick
instant i'm gone don't even
know i'm gone but burn in fire
eaten by lions the lion eats half of you takes a
nap and comes back to eat the
other half and you're not dead
the bible says nebuchadnezzar warmed up that
firmness seven times more now in the bible
seven means what completion perfection
totality that was as hot as it could get
it was so hard the bible says is through the
men that took up shadrach which means and this
is just what i'm seeing here comes these tall
soldiers verse 20. he commanded the most mighty
men that win his army to bind shadrach meshach and
abednego here come these brawny men six foot nine
and they're pulling shadrach meshach and the
fire so hot the men drop dead before they get
to the mouth of the furnace then what happened
those three men said you want to kill us fine
they walked in
i'm not afraid did not some martyrs
go to the state singing hymns
did not peter us to be crucified upside
down according to tradition did not peter
and john leave the sanhedrin rejoicing
they had been chosen to suffer for christ
listen to jesus christ this is my commandment
that you love one another greater love hath no man
than this that a man finish it for me lay down his
life for his friends now christ is saying i
have given the greatest demonstration of love
i gave my life now there's a difference
between giving your life and being killed
now you missed it you missed it
let me try again it's my fault
christ gave up his life
that's voluntary being killed is not voluntary
some of you still didn't get it let me try again
i'm walking down a dark road with my wife
here comes a guy with a gun pointed at my wife
so i step between him and the gun her and the gun
kill me leave her alone that's giving your life
i'm walking down the road with somebody else
a guy sticks a gun i take off
running the photo shoots me
no i'm dead are you with me but i didn't
give up my life are you following me
i took off like a jackrabbit but he shot me
now i died but i did not give up my life i
was trying to save it but freedom
allows you to say here is my life
and so jesus says greater love hath no man than
this that a man laid down his life for his friends
and then he says in a verse first john 3
16 hereby perceive with the love of god
because he lay down his life for us and we
ought to lay down our lives for the brethren
and jesus says in john 10 16 and other sheep
i have which are not of this fold them also
i must bring and they shall hear my voice
and they shall be one fold and one shepherd
therefore that's my father love me because i
lay down my life that i might take it again
no man taketh it from me john
10 18. i have power to lay down
i have power to take it up again jesus is clear i
am not going to be killed i will lay down my life
this is freedom
nothing intimidates
why because there is a higher power
that controls the strings of my destiny
and until you and i learn to live in trust in that
power we will be worried we will be stressed we
will age before our time we will misbehave we will
misunderstand we will neglect spiritual things
as we try to protect ourselves forgetting there
is a god who specializes in protecting his people
the greatest expression of love is
death not murder death voluntary
willing death and jesus said great love hath
no man than this that a man laid down his life
for his friends then he goes on to say ye are
my friends if you do whatsoever i command you
how many friends does jesus have here today
can i see your hands okay he doesn't have
some friends among us hands down let me
ask you a serious question don't answer me
if you're required to give your life for christ
now would you do it god bless you my brother
i'm not joking at any point in the christian's
life god may decide show how much you love me
and christ is clear the greatest expression of
love is laying down the life that is freedom the
united states is the greatest military power on
the face of the earth but they can't stop suicide
bombers with all the technology satellites and
space that can read a number plate on a car they
cannot stop suicide bombers my amateurish theory
is no one can stop a person who is willing to die
they have nuclear submarines and i've
been in one they have apache helicopters
they have f 17 f 18 f 19 f 20
battleships aircraft carriers little cities afloat
can't stop one human being with a bomb
strapped to his chest why because that
man is not afraid to die and so the
intimidation factor does not exist
if you're willing to die for god surely
you're willing to do whatever god says
you can't be willing to god to die for god and
not willing to return a tithe it makes no sense
are you with me a willingness to die tells god
i am willing to do every other
thing that is less intense
are you laughing at the preacher am i making sense
the willingness to die is the ultimate
proof that you love god and i love god
on this religious liberty weekend and
our willingness to die for our faith
is that death that god treasures
there are young men who die for drugs
they die for gangs
they're people who die for
the sake of unprotected sex
am i telling the truth people
die for all kinds of reasons
wrong reasons there are people who die
fighting wars they don't understand
god says die for me
do not allow any earthly power to so intimidate
you that you begin to protect your life regardless
of what effect it has on my kingdom be willing to
die for me and on this religious liberty weekend
i am saying to you my brothers and sisters the
greatest freedom you and i can experience is that
freedom where no power on earth can intimidate
us we're willing to die for the honor of our god
this is what god wants in the last days you know
babylon no longer exists as a physical city or
power but is a real it is a reality in revelation
there's this system called babylon false teachings
babylon requires worship
false worship god has one day of
worship the seventh day sabbath
god says thou shalt not make unto thee any
given image or any likeness of anything that
is in heaven above or that is in the earth
beneath or that is in the water under the
earth nebuchadnezzar of an image and he called all
people nations and languages to bow meaning the
entire world of course the world of the bible is
not the entire physical world but there will be a
greater fulfillment of that when the entire world
will be commanded kneel bow in acknowledgement
of an earthly power that is when we will either
say yes i'll bow and save our lives temporarily
or no i will not bow and run the risk of
suffering the death penalty that will be attached
to this law as verily as death was a penalty
for not bowing to that image death will be
the penalty for not bowing to the law to come
and so this even this morning or this afternoon
let me close god wants people
who are willing to die for him
ella white writes in a mind carton
personality volume 1 page 13 paragraph 3.
satan takes control of every mind that is not
decidedly under the control of the spirit of god
let me say that again mind
carton personality volume 1
page 13 paragraph 3 satan takes control
of every mind that is not what decidedly
under the control of the spirit of god
decidedly means no doubt not god on
weekends satan in the week i mean god seven
days a week 24 hours a day 168 hours a week
god whether i'm in church god on the job god on
the playground god on the bus god wherever god
total control of my life without that we are
praying to the enemy and so today i'm asking you
my brothers and sisters let us ask god to give us
the freedom to serve him regardless of consequence
when the flood came there were eight people who
got into the ark 28 when sodom and gomorrah were
destroyed only one righteous man came out of the
cities now four people came out one righteous man
are you with me the wife became a pillar
of saul the two daughters committed what's
that sexual crime of their father so they
were not righteous one righteous man he did
it when he was drunk so you can't see he
participated one righteous man out of five
cities sodom gomorrah admirals the boy and
bella one when jesus went back 120 disciples
12 in upper room others scattered somewhere what
am i saying most people turn their backs on god
jesus said eat my flesh and drink my blood in john
6 in verse 66 the bible says from that time many
of the disciples went back and walked no more with
him and he asked them is this does this offend
you they said yes what you say is too hard we're
leaving when you leave jesus where are you going
to whom shall we go says peter god bless peter
where are we going thou has the words of eternal
life let me stress this and i'll close the second
time i sell i'll close i usually say it five times
peter said where shall we go uh why did
peter stay thou has the words of eternal life
i don't want to preach the sermons but the reason
to join the church is because they preach the
words of eternal life not because the members
are perfect because one of the 12 disciples in
the early church was the devil jesus said in john
6 70 have i not chosen you twelve one of you is a
devil would you not have joined christ church just
because one was a devil peter said we're staying
because you have the words you don't have
the largest church you don't even have a
church building the cars in the parking lot are
all old but you have the words of eternal life
the word of god says greater love hath no man than
this that a man lay down his life for his friends
but you will never lay down your life for
god if you can't lay down alcohol for him
you will never lay down your life
for christ if you can lay down
that unsatisfied relationship you're in
you'll never lay down your life for god if
you won't stop violating his holy sabbath
because he that is faithful in that which is least
his fifth law is very much it's a principle
by which god functions we need to lay down our
lives in little things every day by denying
self are you with me let me say it again
we need to lay down our lives in little things
by denying cells so by so doing we practice so
that when we get to the big test to really lay
down the physical life we are so accustomed
laying out our lives in little things we let
in our life gladly when the big test comes
in what area do you need to lay down your
life well areas differ from person to person
for someone it may be i watch too much
television and so it interferes with my
ability to understand the bible and so i never
understand the bible and i blame the preacher
you need to lay down your life by focusing on
the salvation of your children not your career
you need to lay down your life by
saying father i will obey you be not
an equally yoked together with unbelievers
i will break off that relationship today
adventist home page 67 paragraph one to
connect with an unbeliever is to place
yourself on satan's ground we need to
lean on our lives by changing our diets
we need to lean on our lives by
changing our recreational pursuits
we need to change later in our
lives by changing the way we dress
on the point of dress let me get into your
business then i'll stop that's what three times
listen carefully to me next time you get ready
to dress for church pray why are you laughing
listen to me carefully pray stand before your
closet and say lord what would you have me to wear
the lord may say none of that stuff
go get a brand new wardrobe
from walmart none of that stuff
now this is serious let me tell you what has been
happening to me recently you won't believe it
i'll tell you i began asking god what should
i wear literally i take ties on my hand i said
father you know the wrong tie can turn one person
off i don't like that guy's tie so i go to sleep
or the wrong shoe so i pray and i say father
which ties should i wear watch you what sucks
this is no joke the underwear i choose can
you say are you with me nobody is there since
i began doing that people have looked at me in
my travels through airports are you a preacher
i was leaving nigeria last november i had my bag
walked up to the immigration he said come profit
you know profits are big in nigeria
so i said what did you call me said
prophet i said why he said it's clear
to me you're prophet and he took off
his cabbage he had prayed for me
and i prayed for him right there
at the immigration office seriously i was leaving
south africa uh three weeks ago coming to the
metal detector and then one of the security
said you are a preacher from the united states
yes i said sister how do you
know that she said but it's
i'm south africa again i was going to i was doing
a crusade on the university campus and i was
i told my driver let's pull off this gas
station let me buy some juice and some gum
you know people in the united states always chew
gum that's how you identify the broad chewing gum
and so i went to a little store i said have
you any juice she said yes so she went to
get the juice it was right next to the liquor
the alcohol when she brought it i said is this
jew she said yes i'll never give you alcohol
i said why not she said you're preacher i said
how do you know that you said but
it's clear to me you're preaching
i went to the very next door next door to
get gum she had none right next door two
feet away i watched it hello there was a
guy at the register he said hello preacher
i said why do you say that he
said the anointing is all over you
i was on a plane they looked
at me up and down yeah preacher
i said yes there's another plane the
young guy sat next to me she looked around
are you a preacher i said yes i said
why'd you say i said you look like one
another plane lady sat next to me
she said what do you do i said i'm
a preacher she said oh i'm glad in case
of turbulence i'm sitting next to you
what am i trying to say when you
decide to let god choose your dress
as a way of laying down your life let me tell
you something fashion is a power in the church
that ruins the church and as i talk about
practicing and laying down your life
practicing die i was in a church i'm about to
finish the full time and these women let me look
around before i say anything i want to get back
home alive no scars i had never seen heels so high
and i said lord what happened to the word modesty
what happened to the word vulgar and
i looked at this lady all of them
said man if she wanted to commit suicide
she just have to jump off that shoe
she doesn't need a tall building
are you with me jump off that shoe
undead what am i saying let's die in the
area of fashion let's lay down our lives
and say father i really want to wear this tight
thing but let me die and wear something loose
lord i really want to wear this pants
looks as if someone painted it on me
but let me die and wear something that covers
me father i want to wear something that's
come down here and the waist is up here in
the bust line here but father let me die
greater love has no man than this that a
man laid down his life for his friends jesus
gave his life you willing to give your life
for christ in the little things listen to me
carefully in the little things now you identify
your little thing your problem maybe fashion yours
may be eating a lot of dead animals whatever yours
is yours may be eat drinking alcohol when no one
is looking taking a puff when the one is looking
gambling on the internet whatever it is looking
internet sites you should not go to whatever area
in which we need to die can we say lord help me to
die in that area match your right hand help me to
die stand up with me help me to die in that area
we need christians willing to die the
willingness to die the ultimate freedom
religious liberty weekend my brothers and sisters
when that law is passed and life is on the line
those who have been accustomed dying for god in
little things will gladly die for god in a big
thing heads bowed eyes closed loving father in
heaven we thank you for your love expressed in
the sacrifice of your son and as he himself said
in john 15 13 greater love hath no man than this
that a man laid down his life for his friends
their god in heaven jesus experienced the freedom
that allowed him to tell pilate valkyries have
no power at all against me father help us to
understand that the supreme court of the earth has
its limits it is not as supreme as we think it is
supremacy lies with you pilate had limited
power you have supreme power and so they god
take away from our hearts any fear we may feel
from earthly supreme courts from earthly rulers
let our focus be obey our god be faithful to
our god that our god may defend us in the time
when it's necessary father we've stood to say
we need to die in this area of that area of that
area dear god give us the courage from on high to
die in the areas where we need to give up cells
whether it's diet dress working on sabbath
whatever it is father give us the courage out of
love for christ to die dearly to god that when
the big test comes we will give up our lives
gladly help us their god to put you first
in everything we do bless everyone who came
save us when you come in jesus name we
pray let god's people say amen and amen